This is peter leave a message yeah peter
this is happy who are those guys huh
whether you guys made a mud
what's going on call me back
When i shut that spell down we
started getting some visitors from
every universe multiverse is real
was that a dinosaur
hey uh doctor michael tired of doing
the whole good guy thing huh
what's up doc you and I should stay in touch
Who the hell are you man. I am Venom. Welcome
back everyone this is my new spider-man no
way home video for morbius in the venom let
there be carnage post-credit scene crossover
i know there are a lot of questions because a lot
of the easter eggs in the morbius trailer are so
confusing there are easter eggs for every single
version of spider-man and venom but thanks to a
lot of the new footage now it all seems like
it makes more sense how they're connecting
all these things and why they're using
easter eggs the way they're using them
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i'm also doing videos for the hawkeye
series episode 1 and episode 2 are dropping later
tonight and i'll be posting my videos for those
tomorrow and because we need to talk about the
venom let there be carnage post credit scene
just big spoiler warning if you have not seen
the new venom movie yet but during the spider-man
no way home trailer we see doctor strange blaming
spider-man for messing up his spell to make
everyone forget that he's spider-man and now
they've started getting quote-unquote visitors
from every universe of the multiverse not just a
couple different universes he says every universe
but then they show the sinister six characters
from the tobey maguire and the andrew garfield
spider-man movies and then connecting things
to venom we saw the venom let there be carnage
post credit scene with the multiverse crossover
venom being teleported to the mcu from the venom
movie universe but rest assured dear viewers
can i wait to see venom go after spider-man but
when they released the newest morbius trailer
just a little while ago it had a billion different
easter eggs for all the different spider-man movie
franchises and there were so many questions about
what was going on the morbius trailer references
the tom holland mcu murder plot points but they
use the tobey maguire spider-man costume to do
that and it's an image taken from a playstation
2 game we have the andrew garfield amazing
spider-man version of ozcorp despite the fact that
we know that they're using willem dafoe's green
goblin from the tobey maguire spider-man movies in
spider-man no way home we have the tobey maguire
version of the daily bugle newspaper despite
the fact that they also reference black cat in
the rhino from the amazing spider-man movies if
you don't remember there was a version of black
cat who had not become black cat in amazing
spider-man 2. we also have the mcu michael keaton
vulture from spider-man homecoming and a direct
name drop reference to venom using his trademark
catchphrase like he says i am venom which is
clearly playing on the we are venom catchphrase
so the morbius trailer is like this giant soup
of every spider-man movie ever and all the venom
movies mixed together with other easter eggs in
a super confusing way i am so confused right now
and i think the answer to how all that makes sense
is in the newest spider-man no way home trailers
during the new trailer we see doctor strange
yelling at spider-man about messing the spell up
them getting visitors from every single universe
in the multiverse and that means that reality has
started to break down like we actually see that
happening in the trailer they're coming through
but i can't stop it as it starts screaming you
literally see the tears in reality around the
statue of liberty and because of that any random
thing from other universes and other timelines can
bleed into the main mcu universe now originally
the morbius movie was set to be released a full
year before spider-man no way home came out so we
would have originally seen this scene of vulture
crossing over with morbius first then we
would have seen venom lethal be carnage in
that post-credit scene with him crossing over into
the mcu being teleported and then almost a year
after that we would have seen doctor strange and
spider-man perform the spell that breaks reality
where everything from all the different movies
start getting mixed together in the mcu so i
think the idea is the timelines of some of these
scenes in the morbius trailer of the morbius movie
in venom let there be carnage post credit scene
are all meant to overlap with what's happening
during the events of spider-man no way home and
it's just that all the movies were coming out at
very different times in real life so we would have
been getting this big interconnected multiverse
story just spread out over the course of a couple
years that feels weird but i'll allow it so i
think the explanation for what's happening in the
morbius movie this confusing mixture of all these
different easter eggs from different spider-man
movies is probably because of the way spider-man
messes up doctor strange's spell effectively
hitting the shuffle button on all of reality
big local man ruins everything kind of moment
classic spider-man it would not be a spider-man
movie if he didn't break reality somehow
it's the only logical way you explain you
have all these andrew garfield versions of things
mixing with tom holland versions and toby mcguire
spider-man details in the venom movies all inside
a sony morbius movie also it does have to be said
second option here there's always the possibility
that the sony people who made the morbius movie
had absolutely no idea what they were doing with
these easter eggs and they just threw a bunch
of different ones at a wall and saw what stuck
without any super deep thought given to the how
in the what of all the details but i think
because they delayed the morbius movie so
much in real life and now it's coming out
after spider-man no way home that gave them
time to fix their explanation for how all these
easter eggs and crossovers work and now they'll
just say that spider-man breaking reality is why
everybody crosses over into the mcu toby maguire
andrew garfield all their sinister six films the
venom character and now morbius for those of you
that want a morbius mcu blade crossover and
when it comes to things like logo easter eggs
and really really small details kevin feige and
the marvel mcu people and then the sony people
on the other side of the aisle separately just
kind of leave that to each other to deal with
in their own movies like some of these sony
movies are now connected to the mcu because
of what they're doing in spider-man no way home
but kevin feige for example only gives them a
few story notes here and there on most of the sony
spin-off movies he's not like a full producer the
way he is on the marvel mcu movies the marvel
people don't control everything that sony does
with the venom movies in the morbius movies
so that just leads to a couple inconsistencies
sometimes between these big crossovers but
thankfully local man ruins everything spider-man
breaks reality it's an easy way to fix all those
inconsistencies and what's actually going on with
this vulture morbius crossover scene in the
morbius movie during the events of the film
morbius gets hauled to the same prison where
vulture was being kept in spider-man homecoming
the morbius movie takes place in new york city
if that wasn't clear you notice vultures wearing
the same white prison jumpsuit that he was
wearing at the end of spider-man homecoming
and when they cross paths here vulture is getting
ready to escape prison break style but here he
knows all about morbius turning into a vigilante
with superpowers so when he says you got tired of
doing the good guy thing huh let's stay in touch
he's trying to recruit morbius for a new team that
he's putting together and that's meant to be a
teaser for future sinister six spin-off movie
plans that sony has they're doing the same thing
that they failed to do after amazing spider-man 2.
so in the amazing spider-man 2 post-credits scene
they have this big scene teasing sinister six that
was meant to set up a solo movie franchise like
a separate sinister six movie that was different
from amazing spider-man 3. obviously things did
not work out for andrew garfield they rebooted
with tom hall and spider-man in the mcu but now
sony is trying to do the same thing a separate
franchise of sinister six movies not all of
them having to feature tom hall and spider-man
some of them will probably feature other versions
of spider-man that they'll eventually introduce
like live-action miles morales spider-man
silk spider-woman sony has already announced
a couple different versions of spider-man
that they're introducing in future movies
so they really are spinning up to more live-action
spider-man into the spider-verse type of stuff
and because there's so much sinister six stuff
going on in the spider-man no way home trailer but
there's only five sinister six characters a lot
of people are now thinking that michael keaton's
vulture will be that sixth member of the team but
here's the thing with sinister six and spider-man
no way home they're not actually the sinister six
team it's just a bunch of villain characters from
different universes who at one point in the comics
were members of a sinister six team it's not like
all six of them will come together and say we are
the sinister six let's go kill spider-man it seems
like doctor octopus actually winds up helping
spider-man fight against these other characters
and the actual villain team up is going to be
something more like green goblin with electro with
sandman and the lizard so yes it is sinister six
but you can't really call it sinister six because
technically they're not all six of them teaming up
together but if there was any confusion about this
yes they are using all this multiverse crossover
to connect the morbius movie to the mcu movies
with the idea that i think eventually they would
love to cross over morbius with mcu blade in other
darker characters i've talked a little bit about
the darker team up that marvel is slowly building
in the background too like you have avengers 5
with the traditional avengers team forming again
but there's also a darker team of supernatural
characters that they're slowly putting together
like the eternals post credit scene you have
blade and the black knight character getting
ready to team up also with the idea that we'll
see that continue in the moon night series i've
already done a moon knight trailer video so i'll
link that at the end of this too but hopefully
that explains how everything is going to be
connected after these next couple of movies
big reminder too tomorrow hawkeye episode 1 and
episode 2 are releasing my videos for both of
those episodes we'll post on wednesday make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that everyone click here for
my full spider-man no way home trailer video
in that invisible andrew garfield scene and
click here for my new moon knight trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!